christ alive that is bloody awful
this is bringing back real bad memories
where are those two geordie fellas now
ain't corner giggling
oh i would honestly have the tip of the
sheep's penis again
over that honestly
okay here we go oh scone or eccles cake
okay so this is from the south and this
is from the north
i'm gonna go cream them jam
at me got a nice jam as well
you put security protected on jam
razors and deodorant yeah but jam who's
rubbing jab i know times are hard
oh god dad
you're loosing this jam for us yeah no
brother i'll do that son
oh there we go put the jam on
hmm
right eccles cake i used to met these in
school
in food technology i think my dad
knew i was never going to join army when
i did food technology as a gcse
oh that smells great
it's all good every fiber and being in
my body's height
obviously it's the eccles cake but my
heart's telling me
there's this gun i'm gonna have to go
with a scum
i'm sorry what's next
oh that's definitely norman and that's
definitely southern
that's like yeah the gentleman's relish
and that's like peace pudding get it
down your neck so gentlemen's relish
is dried and should be paid oh
drive aren't you what
christ alive
that is bloody awful this is bringing
back
real bad memories where are those two
geordie fellas now ain't corner giggling
ah i would honestly have the tip of the
sheep's penis again
over that honestly that is horrific
give me the sheep's kenny day okay this
is the peas pudding in the northern
delicacy
that's just cold mushy peas
that's great i'm gonna say the peas
pudding's the best there definitely
[Laughter]
right these are great if you want to get
pissed quickly on a train
pims and lemonade
i mean it's nice
if i turned up say burnley were playing
away and i turned up right
we carry a bag full of pims they throw
me off at crew they might get off
turned up with these they're like hey so
this
is kind of oh oh john smith's
oh i've not had bitter in ages
that's a great pint i'm sorry but that's
better than any of your pale ales this
is
proper john smith's any day of the week
john smith's the winner there
that's so good i'm out of a bit more
i know the winner already i'll go for
the avocado on toast
first not crushed but or smashed
that avocados had better days i mean
it's nice
but this is just a perfectly beautiful
pork pie
that's just great for snacking that can
be gone in two bites
i've got the jelly on the top roof of my
mouth as well
the clear winner is the pork pie
right at school if you went to someone's
house
and they offered you rabina i always
thought they were posh
maybe on rabbinarin because we always
had vinto
or like cheap squash i'll go for the
rabina first
it is great i think so
this reminds me of school as well before
jamie oliver comes in and
rhett school dinners he used to be able
to get a can of him so
chips and a pizza slice for like 180.
it tastes like pure happiness in a can
vimto definitely the winner
excuse me i like i've been dragged up
sorry
yes i'm jordan north and that was snack
wars for lag bible
i'm gonna burp again get me a renny
i've still got that bloody paste in my
mouth
oh that was rank all right
hey plantain chips of course and uh
walkers oh this could be close you know
let me try the walkers first